enjoy everything
[Music]
you're so great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies
[Music]
[Music]
one two
three
[Applause]
[Music]
get in there
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my mom
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello uh my name is arsen madesta i'm a
registered nurse with dc health kobe 19
emergency response team
i have been playing my part in fighting
against the pandemic by educating the
community on kobe 19 vaccine the safety
the effectiveness and by administering
vaccine to all eligible individuals
i'm currently a side lead at one of the
eight kobe 19 service center throughout
the district
where my responsibility is to make sure
operations on site run smoothly and that
all patients and staff remain safe
this is a moment that many parents and
families across the country have been
waiting for
it is important because it allows
multi-generational households to ensure
everyone in the household is vaccinated
it also allows those parents who are up
to date on their vaccination the same
opportunity to protect their children
against copy 19.
vaccine is the best way to protect you
and your children from kobe 19 and help
in the pandemic
so don't wait
find a kovi 19 vaccination location
nearest you and make it a family affair
by getting everyone in your household
six month and older
vaccinated today
if you have questions about vaccination
for kids under 5 contact your child's
pediatrician or a family physician
and now it is a pleasure to introduce
the person who has been leading the way
forward in our fight against the
pandemic for our community
for a health care worker like me
and for our families it was an honor to
welcome him and the first lady to our
clinic earlier today
the president of the united states still
buy them thank you very much thank you
thanks
as you could tell i didn't want to leave
the clinic
children are wonderful
thank you
our sema and uh for that introduction
and jill and i we're honored to visit
your clinic today
we met with your fellow nurses and staff
who are stepping up each and every day
and we met with families of young
children
and there were about i guess 17 18
families there
waiting for the vaccine shots or have
just gotten their vaccine jobs
and finally covet 19 vaccinations for
children
over five years of age
finally some peace of mind
you know this is uh i should say under
five years we have over five years but
over five months to
six months to five years
and historic this is a very historic
milestone
a monumental step forward the united
states is now the first country in the
world to offer safe and effective covet
19 vaccines for children as young as six
months old
the first time in our fight against this
pandemic nearly every american can now
have access to life-saving vaccines
and we're ready
my administration with the help of the
cdc has been planning and preparing this
moment for this moment for a long time
since i took office we've been committed
to making sure every parent has the
opportunity to protect their children
from cover 19.
we've secured enough doses and we're
launching a comprehensive effort with
states local health departments
pediatricians family doctors pharmacies
rural health clinics community health
centers and other trusted messengers and
partners to get the word out to get help
to get shots in arms
parents will soon be able to start
scheduling an appointment and addressing
vaccines at pediatricians offices
children's hospitals our largest
pharmacies partners and that are
walgreens cvs and walmart are already
scheduling appointments for later this
week
and starting today you can go to
vaccines.gov
and find information and appointments
near you
more and more locations will be ramping
up and more vaccines are delivered to
providers in your areas every day
these vaccines are safe and effective
and are approved after extensive
scientific review of the food and drug
administration the fda and the centers
for disease control and prevention and
the cdc
but i know some parents might have
questions i encourage you to talk to the
doctor
after you make a plan to get your child
vaccinated for your children older than
five years of age for everyone else get
your shots get your boosters
and let's be clear
elected officials shouldn't get in the
way
and make it more difficult for parents
who want their children to be vaccinated
who want to protect them
and those around them this is no time
for politics
it's about parents being able to do
everything they can to keep their
children safe
together
we've come to a long way in our fight
against covert with vaccines treatments
and other tools that are widely
available
more than 220 million americans are
fully vaccinated more than 100 million
americans are boosted
daily deaths due to covet 19 are down 90
and now vaccination is available for
nearly every american
and will remain vigilant we will make
sure that this is not only a good day
but is a good from this point on proof
that there is nothing beyond our
capacity when we work together as the
united states of america i want to thank
you again arasema and may god bless you
our healthcare workers across the
country and continue to continue to step
up and help put this pandemic behind us
and doc do you want to say anything you
don't have to i'm happy to serve all
right okay well whatever
all right
yes
chevron ceo's complaint today he said
that your administration has largely
criticized the oil and gas industry and
at times vilified it and that the
administration would need to take a
change in approach in order to make
progress on reducing energy prices and
to increase supply do you have a
reaction to that sir
it's mildly sensitive
i didn't know they get their feelings
hurt that quickly look we need
more refining capacity
this idea that they don't have oil to
drill and to bring up is simply not true
this piece of the republicans talking
about biden shut down feels
wrong 9 000 of them okay
so they then we ought to be able to work
something out whereby
they're able to increase refining
capacity
and still not give up on
transitioning to
renewable energy they're both within
realm of possibility mr president if you
were to decide to go for a federal
gas tax holiday do you believe congress
would support that and how would you
feel about the fact that those funds are
used for something that is a big
priority for you the pair of roads and
infrastructure and all of that is that
work we have a giant infrastructure bill
we passed
giant
1.2
1 trillion 200 billion dollars
it would be worth it for you to sure
it's not like you know it's not like
before look it will have some impact
but it's not going to have an impact on
major road construction and major
repairs sounds like you may have made a
decision
well let me put this way i'm in the
process i'll have a decision before the
week is out but you asked me an explicit
question
about whether or not how would i feel is
it going to in fact make it difficult to
maintain our roads the answer is we have
plenty of capacity to do that
are you going to talk to president xi
before you make any decision on the
china tariff do you want to have an
engagement with him before you do sing
anything on that
i plan on having a conversation with
president xi we haven't set a time yet
mr president any changes on your planned
trip to israel given what's happened
with the parliament no
i think you spoke with larry summers
recently and he just said that in order
to defeat inflation you would have to
accept higher unemployment what would be
under such backs well there's other uh
there's other
economists who don't think that's the
case
and we're in the process of working
through all of this have you received a
briefing on the guns legislation the
senators say that they've gotten to a
legislative text point a very brief
briefing before i walked in the room to
make sure i say
let them announce it and then i'll speak
to it are you satisfied
let them announce and i'll speak
president mr president are you uh
confident you have i know you looking
for more money from congress for
this vaccine campaign and for for covet
funding going into the fall
uh how much of the supply of vaccines
for these small children
uh is there and and how
many of the nation's kids will you be
able to get vaccinated before you need
more money uh from congress well we'll
get through at least this year we do
need more money but we don't just need
more money for vaccines for children
eventually we need more money to plan
for the second pandemic there's going to
be another pandemic
we have to think ahead
and that's not something the last outfit
did very well that's something we've
been doing for fairly well that's why we
need the money
thank you all thank you
sir um prime minister doris johnson said
recently there's ukraine fatigue uh
there are some leaders who are calling
for negotiations with putin are you
afraid that there's a fracture within
this alliance that that you've said has
been united so far
no i'm not afraid but what i do think is
there at some point
this is uh going to be a bit of a
waiting game
what the russians can sustain and what
europe is going to be prepared to
sustain
and uh
i think we have to that's one of the
things we're going to be speaking that
in spain about thank you all so very
much
you